I was trying to think up a
name for a fantasy world that
might’ve been created by children,
and what I came up
with was Boo’ya Moon,
which sounds like a
childhood place to me.
It’s a place that’s supposed
to be very, very beautiful
and at the same time, very dangerous,
where time doesn’t run the
way that it does on earth.
I wanted it to feel like
the inside of a dream
that’s actually become real.
Boo’ya Moon is part of that, you know,
sort of Stephen King multiverse.
It is a place that was a bit
of a salvation for Scott and
also a desperate necessity.
You could almost call it a purgatory.
There are people that
get kind of stuck there.
It’s also a place that people
retreat from the world.
That’s the place where
she finds her sister.
All this works in a very symbolic way,
in a very metaphorical way,
because even though
these worlds of fantasy are
very fantastical and non-real,
they do represent certain
desires and illusions
and situations that we
experience as humans.
The whole interesting
thing about Boo’ya Moon
is Stephen King’s absolutely
adamant it’s real.